I'm pleased to welcome to the program
today dr. Robert Lustig who's a
pediatric endocrinologist and also
author of the new book the hacking of
the American mind let's start there it's
so great to talk to you and I've been
following your work for some time on
sugar and sugar plays a role in hacking
of the American mind but what do we mean
what do you mean when you say hacking
well first of all thanks for having me
on David so you know hack has a lot of
different definitions the original
definition of hack was a prank that
demonstrated style and whimsy in its
performance Silicon Valley types stole
the word to mean clever solutions to
complex problems but as we all learned
last year
hacking can take on a very different
tone when you are changing the way
people think based on things that go on
maybe in computers but not necessarily
they can be going on in other methods as
well the bottom line is if you are
living in an old reality constructed by
someone else you've been hacked and what
the this book says is that we are
currently living in a very different
place than where we thought we would
find ourselves we currently have four
crises the healthcare crisis social
security crisis the addiction crisis the
opioid crisis and the depression crisis
which no one talks about because well
they think well SSRIs fix it but in fact
24% of Americans are now on SSRIs I
maintain in this book that we actually
only have one crisis and it is that our
minds have been hacked and that the pack
itself is the corporate plot to have us
confuse and conflate two terms to
positive emotions things that go on in
our head pleasure and happiness and how
those two terms have been misconstrued
on purpose basically belie all of the
current societal problems that we are
facing with regard to to tie that
concept into all of the work you've done
within the food industry you know when
you talk about hacking the American mind
I can think of that sort of on two
levels just even in thinking about the
food industry right one would be the
sort of physical responses that you've
identified that can take place as a
result of sugar consumption particularly
and I guess what we would call factory
foods or highly processed foods but then
there's also the sort of food
advertising side of it which is the idea
of how foods particularly processed
foods are even advertised to us and sort
of the emotional component that goes
into that so can you talk a little bit
about that and you could focus on either
or both or however you think it makes
sense to get into that topic sure to be
honest with you I'm not sure I
distinguish the two I think that they
are both a part and parcel of the same
thing
ultimately the food industry has
recognized that sugar is addictive they
know this they know this from their own
work it's actually nicely laid out in
Michael Moss's book salt sugar fat how
the food giants hooked us what he what
he says is that salt and fat are also
potentially addictive the scientific
data actually suggests that salt and fat
increased the salience of sugar but only
sugar generates the signal in the area
of the brain the reward system and only
sugar down regulates the receptors for
the neurotransmitter dopamine which is
the hallmark of addiction its phenomenon
called tolerance so it's actually sugar
and caffeine of course and well sugar
and caffeine we know what that is that's
called a soda the fact that matter is
the food industry recognizes that sugar
is addictive and that is one of the
reasons that they have plied virtually
all processed foods with added sugar and
don't want you to know about it so they
hide behind 56 different names they hide
behind the fact that there's no
recommended daily value
percentage on the side of the Nutrition
Facts label and now they're hiding
behind the grocery Manufacturers
Association of America who basically
lobbied the Trump administration to
deep-six the new Nutrition Facts label
so that we will never find out exactly
what's been put into our food so there
is a very specific plot going on to
number one addicted to our food to
increase their profits and number two
keep us from the information that could
potentially set us free in in terms of
the information you were involved in the
2009 American Heart Association's
guideline on sugar intake and at the
time correct me if I'm wrong it was
women should consume no more than a
hundred calories daily from from what I
guess was called added sugars and maybe
we can talk about what that means and
men no more than a hundred and fifty
calories how much is that in practice in
terms of how it might translate to what
one might eat in a day well so a hundred
calories translates into six teaspoons
of added sugar per day maximum that's
not recommendation that's a maximum and
for a hundred fifty OB nine teaspoons of
added sugar per day now the USDA and the
World Health Organization liberalized
that with their 2016 guidelines to
twelve teaspoons of added sugar per day
but the point is that as a society until
about 10 years ago we were consuming 22
teaspoons of added sugar per day medium
so that means half of the people were
consuming even more than that so you
know quadruple to quintuple the
recommended amount we have now reduced
our median conception to nineteen point
five teaspoons in part because of the
obesity epidemic so we've gone down by
about 10 percent which is good but we
are still three and a half times over
our recommended maximum limit the
question is why do we care it's not just
calories it turns out that sugar has
specific effects on the body in terms of
the aging reaction and in terms of liver
fat insulin resistance and all the
chronic metal
diseases that we know of and it has an
effect on the brain to increase your
consumption so it becomes a vicious
cycle of consumption and disease the
point is that we are consuming so much
added sugar because the food industry
wants us to and Before we jump to that a
little bit so it can you give us some
examples of like if you have a doughnut
how many of those hundred or hundred and
fifty calories that would be the maximum
allotment might be coming from just
added sugar in a doughnut or what
specific food consumption can we give as
an example of how little this actually
is well alright so the one I would
rather in I don't want to do Donuts cuz
everybody knows Donuts or a problem okay
let's let's do something that is
advertised as healthy in fact I you know
use in the book and in my talk let's
talk about raisin bran alright so the
most recent ad package from Kellogg's
now says the following it's got raisins
falling from the sky into a bowl and it
says the road to your happy place is
paved with raisins and flakes and
pavement now what do you read into that
advertisement I mean I guess that the
more you consume the happier you'll be I
don't know yeah and what does it also
infer I mean certainly health in some
way right and pavement running walking I
don't know a via that's telling you
basically in order to get sin get fit
it's about exercise it's not about the
food now what's interesting about that
ad is that the raisins that are falling
from the sky are purple brown black
you know like raisins have you ever
looked at the raisins in raisin bran no
I mean I don't eat that type of cereal
but from what I recall they are very
very sort of like hard and condensed
compared to like if you just buy a
package of raisins they're white okay
that I didn't Arabs or white okay
because they've been covered with
powdered sugar right so
if you actually figure out what the
number of grams of sugar in raisins in a
cup of Raisin Bran would be it would be
about 9 grams however if you look at the
side of the package it says total sugars
18 grams so that means that half of the
sugar in the Raisin Bran is the added
sugar that they coated the raisins in to
make you eat them and if you buy Raisin
Bran crunch that total sugars goes up to
29 grams given that sorry given that
apologize given that we are supposed to
only consume twenty-five to thirty seven
and a half grams that means that a bowl
of Raisin Bran crunch already has
brought you up to your limit and it's
only breakfast talk about a bit about
corn subsidies and how those play into
this because when you look at price per
calorie in most supermarkets a lot of
the cheapest price per calorie foods
have some version of corn in them and
sometimes that's high fructose corn
syrup how much of a role do corn
subsidies have to do with some of the
problems you've identified with the
American food system it's not just corn
subsidies its food subsidies in general
because food subsidies distort the
market there's no economist on the
planet that believes in food subsidies
because they distort the market I say
let the market play out if we did that
people say well then food prices would
go up actually the genie foundation at
UC Berkeley modeled what food prices
would look like if we got rid of all
food subsidies and it turns out that the
only two items that would go up are corn
and sugar exactly what we would want to
go up in order to reduce the amount
available and therefore the amount
consumed so I actually think that would
be a great idea and you know here we
have all of these cities right now
considering soda taxes I have said I say
well you know reduction in consumption
is the goal but if a getting rid of the
subsidy will ultimately lead to
reduction
consumption doesn't that make even more
sense and then we can get even the
libertarians on board because they don't
believe in subsidies either when we take
a step back from the sugar and food
industry specifically and more broadly
into some of the other issues you touch
on in the book hacking of the American
mind what types of solutions should we
be thinking of are we supposed to be
thinking about education should it come
from media should it come from how
politics are financed regulation well
obviously the first thing is you have to
know what's wrong okay you can't fix a
problem if you don't know what the
problem is and right now we are mired in
these four crises thinking that they
have nothing to do with each other and
my the book maintains that these four
crises are actually form manifestations
of the same problem so you have to fix
the problem you can't extricate yourself
from a ditch if you don't know how you
drove into it so the point of the book
is to educate the public on exactly what
the problem really is and who's
perpetrating the problems so that people
can take control of their own lives and
not lead the old reality that
corporations have actually constructed
for them but what's an example of how
one would do that because I imagine you
know I read most of the book in
preparation for the interview and and I
learned a lot about what the problems
are but let's say now that I have a
great grasp of the problem what can i as
an individual do well so what it comes
down to is we're talking about two bio
chemicals in the brain dopamine and
serotonin dopamine is the pleasure
neurotransmitter serotonin is the
contentment or happiness
neurotransmitter they are not the same
two different bio chemicals two
different receptors two different areas
of action two different regulatory
pathways why do we care well dopamine
down regulates its own receptor so you
get a hit you get a rush the receptors
go down you next time you need a bigger
hit to get the same rush and then a
bigger hit and a bigger hit and a bigger
it until finally get a huge hit to get
nothing
that's called tolerance and then
when the neurons in the brain start to
die that's called addiction serotonin
does not down regulate its own receptor
so you can't overdose on too much
happiness but there's one thing that
wrote down regulate serotonin dopamine
so the more pleasure you seek the more
unhappy you get so by knowing what is
pleasure and what is happiness and how
these two bio chemicals differ and how
they interplay with each other is
essential to being able to change number
one your environment in order to help
you increase your serotonin to increase
your happiness and also to be able to
tamp down on dopamine to limit the
reward pathway to rare and special
occasions so in the book I described
four methods that are available to
everyone on the planet and they are free
and they're all things your mother told
you foresee is if you will
Percy connect and that does not mean
face book that means I to I into
personal face-to-face connection and why
is that necessary because you have a set
of mirror neurons in your brain that are
reading the facial expressions of the
person you're talking to in real-time
second to second and you then adopt some
of the same emotions that the person who
you're talking to has that is a process
that we have a name for it's called
empathy and empathy is absolutely
required in order to increase serotonin
so empathy drives happiness and if
you're not making eye contact you are
not generating empathy so Facebook is
not empathy emojis do not convey emotion
because that is not interpersonal
contact you cannot have a relationship
with anonymous second see contribute and
that does not mean to your IRA
contribute means to the world outside of
yourself it can be your family can be
your friends it can be you know general
altruism or volunteerism or philanthropy
to a good cause but it can't be for
brownie points or for you know Boy Scout
badges for
yourself and it cannot be contributing
to your bank account it has to be
outside of yourself so the big question
everybody asks is well what about work
can work satisfy his contribution and
the answer is yes it can with two
provisos one you can see how your work
affects other people and your boss can
see it too if both of those are true
then you can actually derive
contribution through work
third cope and cope means three things
sleep mindfulness and exercise all of
which are designed to reduce cortisol
because cortisol reduces the serotonin
1a receptor and so that that receptor is
what transduces the feeling of
contentment and happiness so stress is
the antithesis of happiness and sleep
mindfulness and exercise all work to
reduce cortisol increase serotonin
increase your ability to commune with
the world and then finally number four
cook and that means real food because
there are three things items in food
that actually matter for these pathways
tryptophane which is the precursor to
serotonin and it's the rarest amino acid
and it's only in certain foods not
others and is only in real food not
processed food omega-3 fatty acids which
are anti-inflammatory anti-seizure life
and reduce the inflammation in the brain
to help serotonin neurotransmission and
that's in marine life but only real wild
marine life not farmed fish and finally
the one that depletes serotonin proc
dose the sweet molecule and sugar coming
all the way back to sugar and processed
food again
so what we are looking for in our diet
is a low sorry a high tryptophane high
omega-3 low fructose diet that's called
real food and unfortunately for us real
food you have to cook processed food is
low tryptophane low omega threes high
fructose so is the antithesis of
happiness and so we Americans have
abdicated our responsibility to cook
over the last forty to fifty years to
the food industry today 33% of Americans
don't know how to cook and if you don't
know how to cook your hostage to the
food industry for the rest of your life
and so are your children we have been
talking about a lot of the material in
the book hacking of the American mind
with the book's author dr. Robert Lustig
I really appreciate you talking to us
about this and I highly recommend the
book to our audience thank you so much
David thanks for having me on thanks for
allowing me to explain what this book is
about